but what's crazier is so here's the
album and a lot of movement just oh look
at the state of you you absolutely prove
it Louie
it's him
like Jackie Magazine in 1978 it comes
with a fold-out poster poster that you
can have that you can have that now you
are letting 50 year-old men down because
this isn't supposed to be going on
you're supposed to let that go about 25
to stay in that shape I find it easy
actually
you know I eat healthy I take care of
myself you know trying to go for the
next 50 okay
neither words want to be here that he
will be in me did a farewell tour
more like yen travelator
[Music]
and then was sicker than any man I've
ever seen
[Applause]